yeah so let's talk toilet gate I mean
there been so many World Championships
these matches with crazy backstories
yeah and the media seems to ignore the
simple ones that are just chess guys
were just playing regular moves I'm not
worrying about any other drama but
whenever we have a one we have one like
kromm link versus two pallav and toilet
breaks out suddenly the media is all
interested absolutely we are blessed
that's what happens I mean and in the
chess world whether it's yogurts or
parapsychologists or what-have-you
somehow that stuff it gets in evolved in
the world of chess so we had left and we
were pretty much there he was Vladimir
Kramnik world champion in this wonderful
line succession all the way back to
Stein it's that when Gary had gone his
own way with Nigel short in 1993 fidei
continued their World Championships so
he had this schism and there was Anatoly
Karpov playing against the likes of
young Tim on as well as got a Kamsky in
1996 and then all hell broke out with
his 128 player knockout matches get all
kinds of champions all kinds of you bet
and somewhere by the year 2006 the fidei
had gone back to the candidates
tournament world championship
essentially eight players best players
in the world double round-robin guy who
wins it wins the World Championship and
that guy was Veselin Topalov
who played magnificent unbelievable that
was just absolutely incredible dynamic
style right sacrificing exchanges like
well nothing for right compensation and
just effortlessly winning it looks I
think you won six out of his four seven
games yes
just killed people exactly so and in
fact I'm pretty close I mean in the
right ballpark I believe he was number
one player in the world so now we had
Vladimir Kramnik who had defended his
match against Pete his title against
Peter Lake oh saying no no I'm still the
world classical world champion and
that's the Phaedo guy but the Phoebe
guy's legit no no no this guy Veselin
Topalov so the real deal
and there ought to be a unification
match so in ELISA we defeat I decided to
host a unification match between the two
claimants
and let's go and then comes the toilet
cake well they also had to agree that
this would be the match certainly Crom
make no gains
yeah to make sure that you got some rena
some or rematch possibilities not
rematch directly but seated into the
next cycle yeah and all that finally
they all agreed on all the particulars
yeah then they start playing the match
is going well for crime Nick you're
right and then Sylvia denial of puts it
into manager to found out that that may
be kramnik has been visiting the
restroom a little too often that's right
and says somebody needs to go in there
with him
right we're thinking maybe something's
going on of course she's talking
computer assistance of course against a
gentleman like Romney right
I mean people took sides immediately
right and Bailey
against denied love and and by extension
to Paulo
yeah it was an infuriating charge with
absolutely no evidence it but it did
what Silvia wanted which was just threw
up the match into chaos and it got
people angry
it got Vladimir very angry because now
his pride his dignity his dignity and
his reputation and his reputation was
being accosted and he said the this is
real garbage because what had happened
is that in him
protests Soviet said that essentially
Vladimir had visited the bathroom too
often we want to close the bathroom and
that was the whole toilet they've issued
and the idea was it started the
competition you have your bathroom I
have my bathroom when I'm white I have
this bathroom and when I'm black I'm
gonna get the other bathroom that's
close to being black right so I don't
have to walk across you so we all had
our separate bathrooms and we went back
and forth the idea was that Sylvia said
well let's just close down the bathroom
the players use that one
and he said well come on I mean the
contract stipulates and this and that
now he Vladimir forfeits a game in
protests in protest of the decision
looks like the match might not even
continue might not even continue but
cooler heads prevail Vladimir gets the
big fat zero
the match continues the match is tied in
the classical chess portion goes to tie
breaks which is unbelievably dramatic
and kramnik plays some of the greatest
rapid chess games ever like games of 30
minutes where his his play was just
unbelievable and he wins the unification
bout which comes then comes the era of
fishy Anand well certainly that kind of
intrigue is something that we did not
want to see happening in chess we
generally don't want to see such as was
the gentleman playing of course just for
some reason we attract that kind of
crazy chaos I psychology often ends up
coming in to our wonderful game just as
you imagine two guys coming to the chess
table both greet each other stand up
shake each other's on hands wish each
other a good game sit down shall I start
the clock and the guy pushes the clock
and pokes him in the eye somehow in
chess we get the poke in the eye which
we cousin
years those two players never shook each
other's hands there I had to face her
face each other so often they never
shook hands
that's correct only recently with a
defrosting of for the iciness of the
relationship we thought it was a
permafrost but you're right there's kind
of been a little bit of the icing de
bellas because of a new feed a rule
fides always changing the rule and now
the rule is even if you hate my guts if
I offer you in my hand at the start of
the game you've got to accept it sounds
like a good rule something I can control
and certainly was a crazy match one that
we'll all remember for a long time
absolutely